okay today I'm going to talk to you
about water treatment we're going to
find out where most of our drinking
water comes from the UK and how its
treated in order to make it safe to
drink so first of all whenever you hear
the phrase potable water it means
drinking water and what we're going to
see is in the UK those three main ways
that we can get our potable water
number one is surface water now all this
means is water which is found or can be
gathered from lakes rivers and
reservoirs was now in the summer months
in England and Wales in particular some
of these some of this surface water can
actually dry up and be scarce so we need
to have other places to get it as well
so second source is ground water now
this is normally we're talking about
aquifers now what an aquifer is is
basically just water which is stored
under the ground within rock so it's
yeah that's that's where we can get that
from in case our surface water has dried
up in summer months we could also get
water which is called waste water now a
lot of industrial processes might have
water which will need treatment but
essentially it could be for example as a
by-product from an industrial process so
these are the three main places where
our potable water comes from the UK now
all of these the water needs to be
treated first that needs to be kind of
clean and safe to drink so in order to
do that there are three different steps
we need to know about the first step is
filtration so we get this water from
these sources and first of all we pass
it through filters now this removes a
lot of the kind of large insoluble
solids so removes a lot of in soluble
solids so twigs gravel whatever might be
in the water gets
moved by the filtration process what
happens next is a process called
sedimentation sedimentation okay so what
sedimentation is is forming a sediment
and in order to do that so there's the
water here and there's the sediment at
the bottom in order to do that you need
to add iron sulfate or aluminium sulfate
now what these two substances can do is
they allow they clump fine particles
together so we add iron sulfate or
aluminium sulfate they react with fine
particles within the water and it forms
this sediment at the bottom so we've now
removed the larger insoluble things and
the smaller particles as well now there
might be some nasty microorganisms in
here that can cause us some harm so we
need to then undergo chlorination so all
that you do with chlorination is
chlorine is bubbled through the solution
oh sorry the water chlorine is bubbled
through the water by doing this it kills
harmful microorganisms so now we've
taken this water from one of these
sources we've treated it and it's now
safe to drink
now in other places not in the UK for
example somewhere like Kuwait or Saudi
Arabia where there's not much of these
options available particularly surface
water and ground wood because it's
really really hot and dry they might use
distillation instead so they might get
salty water from the sea which obviously
you can't is not safe to drink by itself
but then you heat it up the water turns
to a gas it goes through here into the
condenser which is nice and cold and
then the
dancer allows the steam to turn back
into liquid water and then we have our
potable water here so if you want to
learn more about distillation please
watch the video titled
distillation now the final thing that
we're going to talk about is deionized
water because in lots of chemical
experiments in laboratories we need
water to be able to use however in
normal potable water we have different
mineral ions such as copper as a sources
copper calcium and iron so d'art
deionized water is really really
important to remove to remove all of
these different ions because if we have
them in a laboratory they could cause
unwanted reactions so it's really
important to remove them so when we have
when we have chemical reactions in the
lab we don't have any unwanted reactions
and that is basics of water treatment
thanks for listening